hey among all of this bad stuff going on
let me talk briefly about something
really exciting
uh we are approaching 1 billion that's
with a b 1 billion youtube views
you might remember that last september
right around september 15th 14th 12th
something like that
we hit an important milestone 1 million
youtube subscriptions 1 million youtube
subscribers
we are now already almost 40 beyond that
we're almost at 1.4 million subscribers
we've seen 40 percent subscriber growth
in the last 11 months it's incredible
but now
we're moving on to views you can have
tons of subscriptions all over the place
but if those people aren't watching your
videos it's basically worth nothing and
some channels have that situation
millions of subscribers
almost no views we are now approaching a
billion youtube views listen to how nuts
the growth is
last year at this time
our entire channel had 600 million views
the last 400 million views are coming in
basically one year
which is insane and i have only you to
thank for that we are now
at 989
million views that's about ten and a
half million away from one billion
now how long is this going to take we
often get a million views in a day
but not every day so it could be nine
days if we had a really strong nine days
more likely it would be something like
two to two and a half weeks so what are
we doing for this first of all we're
putting together a fantastic billion
view compilation with a nice counter
rolling up to a billion it's gonna start
with old clips and go all the way
through there's gonna be classics in
there that many of our newer viewers and
listeners may never have seen so we're
putting that together it's going to be
like an eight or nine minute long clip
producer pat's been doing a great job
with it and it's going to be ready it'll
be ready to be triggered by us
surpassing one billion views that's
number one number two
yes there's going to be a huge
membership special at one billion of
course there is you better believe it we
are gonna blow memberships out of here
like you wouldn't believe like nobody's
ever seen before in fact uh just get on
my newsletter at davidpakman.com to be
notified there's no specific date
because we don't know when we're going
to hit the billion and then number three
we want this we've never tried this
before okay here this is just an idea
we want to try to make a compilation
of people from the audience calling into
other shows they can be left-wing shows
or right-wing shows and somehow
mentioning david pakman show youtube one
billion views it can be just like hey
you call a friendly show
and you might mention hey will you be
congratulating the david pakman show on
a billion views it can be trolling of
right-wing shows whatever okay the the
only thing is just david pakman show a
billion views mentioned during a call-in
on other shows
send them in if you're able to do it i
know many of you are regular callers to
all sorts of different shows can we get
it in front of mike lindell can we get
who knows dan bongino what are all these
people charlie spork
and then send us a link we'll compile it
together
and hopefully have a funny video in
addition to our billion view compilation
for you
uh by the uh i mean it really should be
early in september
uh could even maybe be in august so
we'll keep uh you updated we are at 989
million on the way to 1 billion